let's talk about AI a little bit
what are your thoughts about gpt3 and
language models trained with
self-supervised learning
it came out quite a bit ago but I wanted
to get your thoughts on it yeah
in the 90s I was in New Zealand and
I had an amazing Professor Ian bitten
who realized I was bored in class and
put me in his lap and he gave me the
task to discover grammatical structure
in an unknown language
and the unknown language that I picked
was English because it was the easiest
one to find a corpus for construct one
and he gave me the largest computer at
the whole university it had two
gigabytes of RAM which was amazing and I
wrote everything in C with some
in-memory compression to do Statistics
over the language
and uh I first would create a dictionary
of all the words which basically
tokenizes everything and compresses
things so that I don't need to store the
whole word but just a code for every
word and then I was taking this all
apart in sentences and I was trying to
find all the relationships between all
the words in the sentences into
Statistics over them and that proved to
be impossible because
um the complexity is just too large so
if you want to discover the relationship
between an article and a noun and there
are three adjectives in between you
cannot do engram statistics and look at
all the possibilities that can exist
yeah at least not with the resources
that we had back then so I realized I
need to make some Statistics over what I
need to make Statistics over so I wrote
something that was pretty much a hack
that did this for
um at least first order relationships
and I came up with some kind of mutual
information graph that was indeed
discovering uh something that looks
exactly like a grammatical structure of
the sentence just by trying to encode
the sentence in such a way that the
words would be written in the optimal
order
inside of the model
and what I also found is that if we
would be able to increase the resolution
of that and
not just use this model to reproduce
grammatically correct sentences we would
also be able to correct stylistically
correct sentences by just having more
bits in these relationships and if we
wanted to have meaning we would have to
go much higher order
and I didn't know how to make higher
order models back then without spending
way more years in research on how to
make the statistics over what we need to
make Statistics over
and this thing that we cannot look at
the relationships between all the bits
in your input is being solved in
different domains in different ways so
in computer Graphics the computer vision
standard method for many years now is
convolutional neural networks
convolutional neural networks are
hierarchies of filters that exploit the
fact that neighboring pixels and images
are usually semantically related in
distance pixels in images are usually
not semantically related
so you can just by grouping the pixels
that are next to each other
hierarchically together reconstruct the
shape of objects and this is an
important prior that we built into these
models so they can converge quickly but
this doesn't work in language for the
reason that adjacent words are often but
not always related in distant words are
sometimes related while the words in
between are not
right so how can you learn the topology
of language
and I think for for this reason that
this difficulty exists that the
Transformer was invented in like a
natural language processing not envision
and what the Transformer is doing it's a
hierarchy of layers where every layer
learns what to pay attention to in the
given context in the previous layer
so what to make the statistics over
and the context is
significantly larger than the adjacent
word yes so the context that this that
gpt3 has been using the Transformer
itself is from 2017 and it's uh wasn't
using that large of a context open AI
has basically scaled up this idea as far
as that could at the time and the
context is about 2048 symbols tokens in
the language these symbols are not
characters but they take the words and
project them into a vector space where
words that are statistically occurring a
lot are neighbors already so it's
already a simplification of the problem
a little bit and so every word is
basically a set of coordinates in a high
dimensional space
and then they use some kind of trick to
also encode the order of the words in
the sentence or in the not just sentence
but 2048 tokens is about couple pages of
text or two and a half pages of text and
so they managed to do pretty exhaustive
Statistics over the potential
relationships between two pages of text
which is tremendous right I was just
using a single sentence back then and uh
I was only looking for first order
relationships and there were really
looking for much much higher level
relationships and what they discover
after they fed this with an enormous
amount of training day they are pretty
much the written internet or a subset of
it that had some quality but substantial
portion of the common draw that they are
not only able to reproduce style but
they're also able to reproduce some
pretty detailed semantics like being
able to add three digit numbers and
multiply two digit numbers or to
translate between probably angle
languages and things like that
so the results that gbt3 got I think
were amazing by the way
I actually didn't check carefully it's
funny you just mentioned how you coupled
semantics to the multiplication is it
able to do some basic math and two uh uh
two digit numbers yes
okay interesting I thought I thought
there's a lot of
failure cases yeah but it basically
fails if you take larger digit numbers
so four digit numbers and so on uh makes
carrying mistakes and so on and if you
take large larger numbers you don't get
useful results at all
and this could be an issue of the
training set down.net many examples of
successful long-form Edition and
standard human written text and humans
aren't very good at doing three-digit
numbers either yeah and they're not
you're not writing a lot about it yeah
and the other thing is that the loss
function that is being used is only
minimizing surprises so it's predicting
what comes next in a typical text it's
not trying to go for causal closure
first as we do yeah
but the fact that that kind of uh
prediction Works to generate text that's
semantically rich and consistent is
interesting yeah so yeah so it's amazing
that it's able to uh generate semantic
consistent text it's not consistent so
the problem is that it loses coherence
at some point but it's also I think not
correct to say that gpdc is unable to
deal with semantics at all because you
ask it to perform certain
transformations in text and it performs
these transformation and text and the
kind of additions that it's able to
perform are transformations in text
right and there are proper semantics
involved you can also do more there was
a paper that was generating lots and
lots of mathematically correct text
and was feeding this into a Transformer
and as a result it was able to learn how
to do differentiation integration in
race that according to the author's
Mathematica could not
to which some of the people in
Mathematica responded that they were not
using the Mathematica in the right way
and so on I have not really followed
these this resolution of this conflict
this this part as a small tangent I
really don't like in machine learning
papers which they often do
um anecdotal evidence they'll find like
one example in some kind of specific use
of Mathematica and demonstrate look
here's they'll show successes and
failures but they won't have a very
clear representation of how many cases
this actually represents yes but I think
as the first paper this is a pretty good
start and yeah so uh do you take home
message I think is that uh the authors
could get better results from this and
their experiments than they could get
from the vein which they were using
computer algebra systems which means
that was not nothing yeah and it's able
to perform substantially better than
gpdsv can based on a much larger amount
of training data using using the same
underlying algorithm